جدد جاك سوليفان مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي عزمي بلاده على مواصلات التصدي
لما سماه العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا من
جانب اخر قلا سوليفان ان رئيسه جو بايدنس
سيرحب خلال القمه الامريكيه الافريقيه غدا
بانضمام الاتحاد الافريقي الى مجموعه
العشرين عضوا دائما واضاف انه عقب القمه
سيكونوا للولايات المتحده ممثلا خاصا جديد
لتطبيق قمه قاده الولايات المتحده
وافريقيا وهو جوني كارسون وبشل يتبادل
السجناء بين موسكو واشنطن اشار مستشار
الامن القومي الامريكي الى ان روسيا طلبت
امورا لم تستطيع الولايات المتحده تلبيتها
لاطلاق سراحه بول
ضموا علينا من البيت الابيض مراسلتنا وجد
وقفي وجد موضع عده طرحها جاك سوليفان
مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي في تصريحاته
امام الصحفيين ما ابرز العناوين
نعم طبعا العنوان الابرز ربما وهو سبب
تقديمها هذه الاحاطه هي القمه
المرتقبه والتي تبدا غدا وتستمر لمده
ثلاثه ايام وهي قمه قاده الولايات المتحده
وافريقيا همم مستشار الرئيس الامريكي
الامن القومي اكد بان الولايات المتحده
تعتزم متابعه مخرجات هذه القمه وبانها من
اجل ذلك عينت الاداره الامريكيه السفير
جوني وهو سفير عمل في عدد من الدول
الافريقيه ممثلا للولايات المتحده وكذلك
كان مساعد
لسابقا
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي في عهد باراك
اوباما كان مساعدا مختصا بالشؤون
الافريقيه لديه خبره كبيره في القاره
الافريقيه واكد طالب بان الاداره
الامريكيه تعتزم متابعه مخرجات هذه القمه
من خلال عملي وبانه وظيفته ستكون
همم تنسيق ضمان تنفيذ مخرجات هذه القمه
خلال هذه القمه نتوقع ان يكون هناك اعلان
عن مساعدات امريكيه جديده للقاره للقاره
السمراء وكذلك همم سوف تركز هذه القمه على
ضروره تعزيز المجتمع المدني في العمل داخل
دول افريقيا وهكذا
سوف تتحدث وتتناول في يومها الختام واليوم
الابرز ربما هو الذي سيشارك فيه الرئيس
عفوا بالقاء كلمه همم سوف تركز على الامن
الغذائي للعالم وكذلك لافريقيا وذلك في
ضوء الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا والتي
بحسبكس جاكسون تعرق العمليات بيع الاسمده
نظرا لارتفاع اسعارها وتعرق العمليات
الزراعه في القاره السمراء نظرا لارتفاع
اسعار اسمده اللازمه للمنتجات الزراعيه في
اا افريقيا كذلك بالنسبه لي اوكرانيا اكد
سوليفن عزم الولايات المتحده همم مساعده
اوكرانيا في مواجهه ما وصفه بالعدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا
ومساعد ومواصله تقديم المساعدات الدفاعيه
والامنيه سواء كان عن طريق الولايات
المتحده منفرده او عن طريق مجموعه السبع
كما راينا اليوم في بيانهم واكد صارفا بان
سبب عدم اطلاق صراحه رهينه الامريكي
الثالث لدى روسيا طويلا هو ان روسيا طلبت
من الولايات المتحده بالمقابل مطالب لا
تتمكن الاداره الامريكيه في الوقت الحالي
من تلبيتها لكنه اكد عزم الاداره
الامريكيه على العمل جاهده من اجل اطلاق
سراحه كما فعلت مؤخرا مع بريتني
شكرا لك وجه وقفي مراسلتنا من البيت
الابيض